Episode 17
Take two.
[Laughter]
I still can't get this.
Hi. I'm Carrie Anne and welcome to Crash Cource Computer Science.
As we've disgusted throughout the series,
computers have come a long way from mechanical devices.
Cable--
With CPU requests [stuttering].
The RAM can transmit just--
AH!
Thingsing--
[Crying]
You need like a, like something to punch.
[Laughter]
Fetch the code, execute. Fetch the code, execute. Fetch the code, execute.
Fetch the code, execute.
And so on.
This may now desire, require 3 clock cycles to execute one instruction.
I messed up the last line!
[Crew laughs]
No word on weather it can run crisis or max settings, but I sus-- suspe--
And whenever possible, execute instructions that require different parts of the CPU.
Over the next 60 years these business machines grew in capability.
I've got this. I've got this. Come on.
Over the next 60 years this business p--
busi--
Ah!
Over the next 60 years these business p--
No.
Brain.
Let's go to the Thought Bubble.
Crew: Yeah. That was great.
Crew: Okay. So, uh,--
Relax.
Crew: Yup!
[Laughter]
Chillax time!
Un-nested between if and end.
If
It's in another line.
[Laughter]
Because computers with text so often, there are many functions--
I don't got this.
I really don't got this.
Let's cover some programming--
The American mathematician Alonzo Church, first presented a solution to this problem in 1939.
He-- No. That's the wrong date.
The result was a high level, easy to use--
I'm reading faster than the words coming up.
[Crew laughing]
Alex, are you dying?
Kilby built his first IC's out of geranium.
A rare and unstable material.
Germanium?
I said geranium.
Which is a flower.
Just like a film can be projected to fill the entire movie screen, we can focus a photomask onto a very small patch on silicon.
Crew: It's not "just like". I like, the opposite.
[Laughter]
I feel like I'm a stop sign.
Interfacing with early peripherals was very low level.
Requiring programmers to know intimate--
It sounds a bit weird.
I feel like I'm playing bagpipes.
[Laughter] [Imitating bagpipe sounds]
Ekka and his friend--
No.
They probably weren't mates.
[Laughter]
These would wait for the right spot to rotate underneath them to read or write a bit of data to keep this delay as fast as possible.
To keep track of what a file is and what's a directory.
Just give up there.
Non-volatile, solid state drives.
Or SS--
No one calls them SSD's.
Crew: I call them SSD's.
Really? Crew: Yeah!
Or SSD's as the cool kids say.
Or just Brandon.
Crew: Hey!
Luckly, newer versions of Windows have better protections and usually don't crash quite that often.
[Laughter]
And that's a wrap on that video.